in der neuen klasse sind wir mal mit der
schule zur berufsberatung gegangen und
da mussten wir so ein test machen und
ich weiß nicht ob wir so was auch schon
mal gemacht habe aber bei mir kann da
wirklich ganz ganz komisch ergebnisse
warum ich glaube es sollte schreiner und
tischler oder so etwas werden also
wirklich überhaupt nichts mit dem was
ich heute mache
und wir haben bei uns im team gefragt
und da sah das nicht anders aus einer
von uns sollte okay bauer werden und ein
anderer fisch wird
aber woran liegt das eigentlich
deutschland fehlen die fachkräfte
gleichzeitig wollten immer mehr leute
studieren seit 20 jahren gibt es immer
mehr erstsemester klar ein studium ist
ja auch ziemlich attraktiv damit werde
ich nicht nur schlauer sondern auch mal
besser bezahlt zumindest in der theorie
aber was wenn das jeder so macht dann
haben wir ein großes problem und ein
universitäts professor aus den usa hat
da eine ziemlich radikale lösung wir
schaffen die uni für jeden ab ob das
wirklich so sinnvoll ist und was er
damit genau meint damit beschäftigen uns
heute in diesem video
herzlich willkommen bei doktor watson
[Musik]
warum gibt es eigentlich universitäten
ganz vereinfacht gesagt für zwei dinge
erstens für forschung das schaffen aber
nur die besten studierenden mit dem
größten durchhaltevermögen und warum das
verdammt oft unfair und schlecht bezahlt
ist darüber machen wir bald eine ganze
video reihe also vergesst nicht den
kanal zu abonnieren wenn ihr das nicht
verpassen wollt und der zweite weg von
universitäten ist es geworden zumindest
menschen für den arbeitsmarkt fit zu
machen
mit wissen und mit skills diese beiden
seiten haben eigentlich immer ganz gut
miteinander funktioniert aber in den
letzten 20 jahren kriselt es in der
akademischen welt und das hat natürlich
wie so oft mit dem lieben geld zu tun in
den usa kostet ein studium umgerechnet
zwischen 20 und 40 tausend euro pro jahr
in england können das gerne mal 10.000
euro pro jahr sein
und bei unseren niederländischen
nachbarn immerhin noch 2000 euro
jedes jahr wenn nicht privilegiert genug
ist und so viel geld mal eben auf der
hohen kante hat aber trotzdem studieren
möchte der muss entweder nebenbei
arbeiten gehen oder immer häufiger einen
kredit aufnehmen und den mann dann nach
dem studium abbezahlen muss plus zinsen
ich meine stellt euch das mal vor die
müsste schon vor dem studium das sie
einen kredit von durchschnittlich 40.000
euro aufnehmen müsste
viele verdienen das nicht mal im jahr
die usa stützt das gerade in eine
waschechte krise da sind die schulden
von studierenden auf einem all time high
von 1,6 billionen dollar vor allem in
diesen ländern müssen universitäten
verdammt gute argumente liefern warum
man einen riesigen kredit aufnehmen
sollte das wissen was mir das studium
bringt und die skills die ich dort
lernen müssen so wertvoll sein dass er
sich für mich lohnt die schulden
aufzunehmen
jetzt gibt es aber kritiker die sagen
folgendes inzwischen ist es nicht mehr
wichtig was man studiert hat sondern nur
dass man überhaupt studiert hat ein
studium soll also nicht nur geld sondern
auch zeit verschwendung seien
einer dieser kritiker ist brian chaplin
ein wirtschaftsprofessor aus den usa und
sagen wir mal so ich glaube nicht dass
er ein wirklich großer fan von seinem
arbeitgeber der george mason university
ist denn in seinen arbeiten und büchern
analysiert er das ganze so tausende
stunden lang lernen wir fähigkeiten die
komplett irrelevant für den arbeitsmarkt
sind deswegen sollten wir literatur
analysen mit business english
austauschen
wofür braucht man überhaupt super
fortgeschrittene mathematik wenn er
später sowieso mal alles computer machen
also die alte frage die ihr bestimmen
doch aus der schule kennt wofür brauchen
wir das alles wenn es nach apple geht
gar nicht der arbeitsmarkt bezahlt mich
nicht für die inhalte die studiert habe
oder wie er es nennt nutzloses wissen
sondern dafür was mein uni zeugnis über
mich aus sagt nämlich dass ich arbeiten
kann oder wie er es nennt extreme lange
weile aushalten kann
die ganze zeit und vor allem das ganze
geld das man in den usa in ein studium
steckt wäre woanders besser investiert
und zwar bei leute von vornherein
einfach das lernen würden was sie später
im job wirklich machen werden und damit
mein kind nicht nur sozial oder
geisteswissenschaftliche fächer dieses
vorurteil kennt man ja auch in
deutschland sondern fast alles in jedem
bereich wäre es besser wenn leute
anstatt zu lernen wie man arbeitet
einfach arbeiten würden
klar es gibt wichtige theoretische
grundlagen für einen job zum beispiel
als maschinenbauer oder mediziner aber
zu viele studiengänge starten mich mit
fachwissen aus dass für forscherinnen
und forscher vielleicht wichtig ist aber
auf dem arbeitsmarkt überhaupt nicht
gebraucht wird
mit der aussage habe ich übrigens ganz
große probleme also nicht falsch
verstehen dass das hier meine meinung
wäre aber dazu komme ich gleich noch
unterm strich sagt er das einfach viel
viel weniger leute studieren sollten und
der staat weniger geld in bildung
stecken sollte für caplin hätten wir
damit ein win-win szenario arbeitgeber
bekommen bessere fachkräfte und
angestellte verdienen mehr weil sie
anstatt von drei bis fünf jahre nutzlos
im studio diese zeit genutzt haben um
gut indem zu werden was sie irgendwann
einmal machen müssen nämlich arbeiten
okay das ist eine sehr radikale ansatz
aber für uns hier in deutschland ja
eigentlich irrelevant oder denn ich
meine wenn es um hunderttausende euro
geht dann kann ich das irgendwie
verstehen aber man darf an der stelle ja
auch nicht vergessen dass es in den usa
ja komplett andere startbedingungen gibt
in deutschland kann ich studieren was
ich möchte
ohne mich für die nächsten 20 jahre zu
verschulden zum beispiel hier in nrw
kann ich mit ungefähr 560 euro im jahr
studieren und es sogar noch ein
bahnticket mit drin
ob ich damit meine zeit verschwende ist
ja dann auch eigentlich meine sache oder
naja nicht ganz denn studieren in
deutschland kostet nichts war nichts
aber das heißt ja nicht dass es
kostenlos ist die kosten die in england
den usa oder den niederlanden die
studierenden tragen übernimmt bei uns
der staat und das geld das der staat zur
verfügung hat kommt durch steuern nur
weil ich als student nichts bezahle
heißt das nicht dass man studium keine
geldverschwendung sein könnte wenn jeder
studiert muss das studium auch für jeden
bezahlt werden und das ist teuer so
teuer das unterfinanzierte fächer
darunter leiden und wir vielleicht
irgendwann mal an den punkt kommen
könnten dass das studium doch wieder
geld kostet ok im vergleich zu den usa
ist vieles anders
manches ist ähnlich aber eines ist
gleich steigende studierendenzahlen kann
man als geldverschwendung sehen und je
mehr leute studieren desto weniger
machen eine ausbildung und das führt
dazu dass uns fachkräfte fehlen
zusätzlich noch zum demografischen
wandel deswegen schlägt brian chaplin
vor
wir sollten das studium für jeden außer
forscherinnen und forscher abschaffen
und jetzt kommen wir mal zu meiner
meinung das große problem mit dieser
lösung ist dass man alles an der
wirtschaft ist aber nicht jeder zweck
von einem studium lässt sich finanziell
messen was ist mit meiner persönlichen
entwicklung die ich während eines
studiums durchmache unabhängigkeit
freunde eine neue sicht auf die welt
oder einfach nur spannendes wissen über
themen die mich interessieren
charakterentwicklung
das ist super wichtig lässt sich aber
nicht in geld aufwiegen
und genau so dass die skills aus einem
studium schwachsinn sind kann ich nur
begrenzt verstehen auch wenn du
vielleicht mal irgendwo arbeitest wo du
die informationen aus deinem
kulturwissenschaften studium nicht
konkret brauchst gibt es ja trotzdem
skills die erhalten bleiben
quellenarbeit zeitmanagement oder
argumentieren aber vielleicht der
hauptgrund warum captains these für mich
unsinn ist ist dass wir nicht wissen
können was in der zukunft mal wichtig
sein wird
unser aktuelles wirtschaftssystem kommt
von menschen die an uni studiert haben
und nicht arbeiten gegangen sind
ohne langweilige und nicht vermarktbare
theorie von studiengängen gäbe es gar
keinen markt das als brian chaplin würde
gar nicht erst darüber philosophieren
können ob man universitäten nur noch für
ein paar besonders schlaue leute auf
machen soll
das ist nicht nur elitäre ausgrenzung
sondern auch für die zukunft gefährlich
gerade ist praxis für den markt
vielleicht besser als theorie aber wer
kann uns schon sagen dass sich das nicht
einmal ändern wird
[Musik]
auch wenn brian chaplin meiner meinung
nach verdammt komische ideen hat muss
ich ihm in einer sache zustimmen
uni ist nicht für jeden etwas und das
muss sie auch nicht sein nur weil ich
das studium für mich persönlich sehr
wichtig fand kann ich natürlich nicht
für jeden sprechen und was in der schule
oft nicht so richtig betont wird juni
ist theorie und das kann sehr sehr sehr
trocken sein
das heißt nicht dass nicht das stören
muss wenn du richtig bock hast
kunstgeschichte oder philosophie zu
studieren dann macht das aber wenn du
lieber praktisch arbeitest du wieviele
dann gibt es lieber zu und mache eine
ausbildung oder eine fachhochschule
man kann auch ohne bachelor oder master
viel geld verdienen und komplett
unabhängig vom geld glücklich werden
mein ratschlag macht das was für dich
das richtige ist und ich weiß dass das
gerade so klingt wie die oma und die
effektiv keinen richtigen ratschlag
gegeben habe der irgendwie sinnvoll ist
aber das ist irgendwo das was ich als
lebens ratschlag mitgeben kann was ich
euch gerne noch mit gäbe ist der post
von wakeboard bei den ich sehr sehr toll
finde wie man einen beruf in der
wirklich zu einem passt findet ihr unten
in der video beschreibung jetzt
interessiert mich aber eure meinung
studiert ihr oder habt ihr euch gegen
ein studium entschieden und vor allem
seid ihr mit eurer entscheidung
zufrieden und wenn ihr jetzt gerade abi
macht was wird eure entscheidung sein
lasst es uns in den kommentaren wissen
ansonsten wie immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig